preview when Bella wakes from an
afternoon slumber outside her village
she knows her short life will soon be
editin an ancient and powerful monster
mog chothra is coming and Bella will be
offered as a sacrifice of appeasement
this is a high honor both for Vella and
her family were very proud of you
elsewhere Shay rises for another mundane
day aboard the bossa nova a spaceship
designed to keep him safe and free from
harm the result is a child's paradise
turned prison as Shay can do little else
but eat ice cream play with toys and
receive hugs from his animatronic
friends together Bella and Shaco star
and broken age a coming-of-age story
that finds both heroes struggling to
break free of their stations in life you
can switch between these two freely and
help guide Vella and Shay as the
innocent worlds of their youth collapse
around them to reveal the often harsh
realities of adulthood it's a somber
tale but one that is tempered by the
colorful and humorous style that has
become developer Double Fine's hallmark
Bella decides against the warnings of
her family to fight mog chothra while
Shay devises a plan to outsmart the
overbearing spaceships and take control
of it for himself you accomplish both by
talking with others and collecting items
tasks which are punctuated with some
great humor that keeps you excited to
see what sorts of wacky scenarios the
game will throw at you next
whether you're hopping between head
shrieking teleporters or steering a
spaceship by way of knitting a scarf
broken age isn't afraid to juxtapose
it's more serious plot points with
ridiculous activities
however while delightfully silly both
Bella and Shea's worlds maintain a
consistent logic that helps you work out
these problems solving a puzzle is never
a matter of combining two wildly
different things to make some random
object related to the task at hand they
may be silly but these puzzles also make
sense however since the game is asking
you to juggle two entirely separate sets
of puzzles one for Bella and one for
Shay the puzzles themselves feel rather
basic and their solutions straight
forward the complexity of these puzzles
does ramp up slowly as you progress
further in the game but get cut short
when you reach broken ages early
conclusion presumably since this is only
the first half of a full game the
puzzles will continue to grow more
complex in the second act but this
remains to be seen when you're not
worrying about brain teasers broken ages
vibrant world is a delight to explore
the bright pastel colouring and soft
lighting Lin the game's backdrops a
storybook aesthetic that complements its
humorous writing while also contrasting
and emphasizing its central plotline at
times you feel as if you're dashing
through the pages of a dr. Seuss book
some fantastic voice work further
enhances this experience with a couple
of great performances by characters seen
only once or twice in the game broken
ages world may be fun to explore but
don't get too comfortable just as you
fall into a steady groove with its story
and its puzzles the game ends thankfully
the ending manages to provide some
resolution while also enticing you for a
second act it's obvious that while this
game functions as a standalone release
it's not designed to be one this opening
act has set the stage for an engrossing
tale of childhoods end let's just hope
the payoff is as fulfilling
you